for so many years
to come to Argentina I go to work a
vacation with this with you two
and then you saw the human beings
you're the best
come from Spain Madrid Barcelona and
Malaga and the people here will be
really hot really enthusiastic and the
band will enjoy
I'm from Rosario Argentina Adam sponge
with my heart I have waited for moments
since I was 15 and I'm 18 years old
right now I want to be waiting
well Sunday Monday Tuesday today's waste
so that's four days ago
many is the worst day of your life
I'm just once on make you smile baby
one song that's right
under the what this leads me to the
restaurant
well I don't I don't have any money
words to say because I'm so nervous for
further show
that's my one of my favorite it was my
first LP
welcome to our country thanks for coming
Joseph and finally two walls
she's the key of the 21st century we are
resilient we are very happy to have you
two here in breath you